welcome to the across the spoiliverse
podcast I'm your host Paul AKA James
Bond James Bond and this week we're
joined by Greg from real rejects we've
also got a sponsor
surfsharkvpn Greg how's it going are you
excited with all the news this week
finally some positive news there is so
much news I did not realize how much
news there was until Paul's like hey I
outlined Today's Show sends me this
document so much news in there that's
why you're the breakdown Master the
master at preparation are you feeling
okay I know you've been recovering this
week I'm a little under the weather
myself but the show must go on you doing
all right yeah I've had a cough pretty
much every night for the last two weeks
just constantly coughing through the
night
um one of my kids went into a e on
Friday for a couple of hours so just
being a stressful time but positive
thoughts everyone says we're being too
negative with Greg we've finally got
some good news we'll have to focus on
the positive let's do it
so you guys might have seen that the
strike is over we will be covering that
in just a bit but as always we're gonna
break down the weekend box office
figures talking about being positive
it's not been that good for The
Expendables 4 or X Bend or four Bulls as
as I call it um unfortunately off a 100
million dollar budget it's made 8.3
million and it has been quite a big flop
based off that opening weekend now every
time we say to flop based off the
opening weekend they say well it's still
got a big run that's fair enough but
comparing it to the other movies the
first film made 34.8 million first
weekend second one 28.6 million third
one 15.9 so it was on a downward Trend
but 8.3 million off a 100 million dollar
budget not not that not that positive
Greg actually I realize that now what
are your thoughts on it I think if
there's a shot for it to rebound because
the fact they have Tony John Eco wires
that that's where they have an
opportunity to potentially rebound is in
an international market
to me this is a massive disappointment I
I think the Expendables franchise is
fine I've never really been in love with
it I've kind of liked all the first
three the you know like part three got a
lot of flack for deciding to go PG-13
instead of R so this is supposed to be
the return to form and to me there's no
excuse I've previewed a lot of the
reviews on it to me there's no excuse
for why this shouldn't have had at very
minimum the best hand-to-hand fight
scenes you got Jason stay at them in
here you got eco-wise from the raid
films you got Tony John here this should
have been killer even if the movies plot
and story and dialogue sucked the fight
scenes should have been the Talk of the
Town and supposedly that's not even that
great so yeah it's a bummer it's a
disappointment
um I do think I had this weird thought
when I woke up this morning that if
there's a way they could reboot The
Expendables in like a decade from now
they they could probably do some kind of
21 Jump Street type of style the way how
they they took a a serious show and then
made some kind of action comedy out of
it so that was something that was like
self-aware of a little bit satirical I
think they could do that down the road
with an Expendables reboot as opposed to
this machismo serious thing something
that's a little bit more tongue-in-cheek
so there's there's hope for the
franchise yet I've never actually sat
down and watched any of them
um I'm not a big fan of most of the cast
but it's always just being on in the
background somewhere I know what I know
what it's about but I do kind of feel
like this sag after a strike might have
affected this a bit I know sometimes we
talk about how when actors can't promote
it doesn't make a massive difference in
our opinion but however with this having
such a big cast of 80s action Stars you
know I feel like they could have done a
lot of creative things that
Unfortunately they can't do because of
the way things are going in the world at
the moment also the the audience skew on
this was you know as suspected it was
more towards an older audience who might
be waiting for it on streaming even
characters like well not characters but
actresses like Megan Fox you know even
her base at the moment it's not the
young kids it's it's more you your late
20s 30 year olds that that grew up with
her um so there wasn't that massive skew
towards young kids to go and see this
film which I feel like you sometimes
have to do when you're trying to bring
in all ages because it's the kids who go
see the movies and that's why things
like Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny didn't do as well as it could
have because it it aimed more for that
older audience who who don't always go
to the cinema
um but yeah good news for Oppenheimer
whilst this is going on it's now past
926 million dollars worldwide which is
absolutely insane yeah I can see it
hitting that predicted 950 might even go
on to do a billion Christopher Nolan I'm
sure I basically had a brand deal that
hit me up and was like we want you to
advertise this thing in your Oppenheimer
breakdown when it releases digitally
everyone was saying it was coming
October we we've now had to kind of move
things about because the digital release
is coming November and I feel like
Christopher Nolan's pushed that back and
it might actually hit the billion if
it's got that extra bit of time just to
continue in the IMAX format it hasn't
got much competition at the moment
nice IMAX format yeah it's it's going to
be getting people in and I might might
buy a couple more tickets Greg just to
chill for the guy yeah I want to see it
again I've been dying to watch it again
because we have yeah the the theater out
here the Universal City Walk where Nolan
tests his he tests his films there and
Barbie had the IMAX release yet Barbie
did not play at that Theater which is
the one that people flock to for iMac so
even Barbie could still couldn't Edge
their way in
they kept it at Oppenheimer uh even on
the weekend Barbie was having it but I'm
pretty sure it's getting booted when
that Taylor Swift movie comes out that's
a yeah that's a big deal out here uh I
even got tickets for the Taylor Swift
movie biggest movie of all time by the
sounds of it I can't wait yeah but
speaking of Bobby excited
I'm sure you are but it's not the Taylor
Swift podcast I'm sick of it so you're
saying it everywhere what you mean it's
been no way home I'm furious
make real Cinema um yeah so speaking of
Barbie this comes from Eric Davis
um so Barbies hit 630 million
domestically which means that it's now
outgrows the first two Avengers film and
every single Star Wars film except for
the force awakens wow yeah so it's also
gross outgrowsed every single DC film
today as well and which is a pretty
crazy like yeah have you seen it yet no
not yet still not seen I've been ill
Greg
what what kind of excuse is that I've
been ill I can't watch it what a weird
excuse I'm working too hard
um but yeah I got sent a TV show
recently the first three episodes of
that are releasing very soon and it's a
TV show I've been looking forward to for
a while I've been obsessing over it and
uh we've got a very very in-depth
breakdown coming out on it so I've just
been working on that getting that ready
and I've not been able to watch Barbie
I'll bring it in tomorrow um I feel like
I'm that kid at school who's like he
borrows something off you and you're
like can you can you bring it back in I
I'm bringing in I'll bring it in
tomorrow I promise you Greg this time
next week I'll have seen Barbie I
promise you that I won't so don't ever
bring it up again there's been so much
edification on my end and then the rest
of the World's End and I'm so hoping you
like it I I just want you to walk out
going I like this movie I've seen those
comments where people are like no Paul
stick to your guns don't watch this
movie no you must watch it one day sit
down with your life and enjoy it I'm
gonna Panda to both bases and I'm gonna
say I read the Wikipedia and then it's
kind of like oh he's not really seen it
but he knows what's happening so yeah
another
um statistic that's come out bad news on
this one Greg Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one has ended its
domestic run earning just 172 million
which makes it one of the biggest flops
of the air unfortunately
I feel it was mainly down to the release
date I remember going to see uh I think
it was the fourth Mission Impossible on
boxing day and that felt like the right
time for mission impossible to drop you
know it's a big big Christmas
celebration sort of what they're doing
with Aquaman at the moment where it's
it's coming out towards the end of the
year and it's like an avatar you know
what I mean it's it's an event film you
go out and see it over Christmas you
have a good time you're not there day
one necessarily but over the holidays
people got to see it whereas I feel
releasing it when they did which was the
weekend after Indiana Jones and just
before Bob and Heimer kind of put it in
a weird place where it was kind of
sandwiched between you know a film that
didn't do so well but then two films
that did absolutely insane and just pay
up all the box office so unfortunately
that's not done that well we obviously
have part two coming soon
I'm guessing the studio is going to be
worried I'm guessing Tom Cruise is going
to be a bit annoyed because obviously
top gun Maverick did so well a lot of
people kind of felt this was a spiritual
successor to that almost and
I feel I expected the same audience for
top gun Maverick to turn out for this
and clearly they haven't uh which is a
shame because it's quite a good movie
just yeah obviously didn't interest
people enough to go out and check it out
I don't think it generated as much of
that uh that desire for repeat viewing
as well even for a lot of people who
really liked it I think the other ones
kind of provided that cinematic
experience and yeah I mean it's really
is so hindered by the amount of stacked
releases uh Oppenheimer and Barbie were
immediately following the release so it
makes sense that it would be that
affected at the same time you know like
I
again I was not one of the people who
was super enamored with the film and I I
liked it overall but I wasn't in love
with it and I'm a huge fan of the French
I'm a mess I've seen every one of them
multiple times and yet even as a massive
fan of it I was like like I saw that
actually a fun fun little fact here uh
because I saw it on a Dolby and then I
went to iMat I bought tickets and I
watched on IMAX opening weekend just to
kind of get my second opinion in and
every Mission Impossible film starring
from Ghost Protocol their iMac scenes
they would take up the entire screen
like that was part of the event of the
Cinematic experience top gun Maverick
would have that too where they shot it
with IMAX cameras but then in this movie
it never converted it never it never did
the full IMAX experience which was kind
of a letdown and a lot of people when
they were leaving the screening were let
down by it too and apparently because of
the fact
that this is just a rumor but I firmly
believe it because I know they shot this
with IMAX cameras so it made no sense to
me why I did not fully convert is that
Tom it costs extra money to con have
that conversion happen in a movie and
Tom Cruise did not want to throw down
for that due to the fact that it was
only going to be playing in IMAX for one
week but I do think that would have
helped generate a little bit more buzz
and excitement and necessity to go watch
it in that one week that it did release
if they didn't convert it but then again
it was just one week so I understand Tom
Cruise's decision to not want to
ultimately make that conversion as a fan
though of IMAX camera experience that
was a massive letdown to not experience
it with the true IMAX experience
I can't actually remember maybe the your
Cinema ripped you off but I can't
remember if it had the switching aspect
ratio but maybe it didn't maybe Tom
Cruise that's going to be the new
conspiracy theory you know when there's
been all those conspiracy theories where
people go to the cinema and like no
one's here but it says it's sold out it
this is the new one it says it's IMAX
but there's no changing yeah so yeah
well sad bit sad for Tom
um but you know some good some good news
there some bad news there there were
winners and losers who have been super
negative we just read a comment before
we started the the episode about how
negative we were so we're like we'll try
to be positive for once but uh yeah
those comments are really getting to us
maybe you'll be negative
um so uh the the strikes obviously ended
we're gonna talk about that more in just
a bit but off the back of this you might
have noticed they've started announcing
just lots of things that they've clearly
had to hold back that they're working on
because you know that they don't want to
basically be seen as scabbing now one of
the big things that's come out is that
the office is being rebooted and Greg
Daniels will return as the showrunner
Greg your first thoughts my first
thoughts are a question isn't there an
Australian version coming out right now
I thought there's really yeah I I
believe there's an Australian version
that's supposed to come out on Amazon uh
either later this year or early next
year
uh where it's like a female lead the
cast but it is the office but Australian
version I remember Ricky Gervais putting
out some statement about it no no idea
not seen it there's like an office
Cinematic Universe it's kind of crazy to
know that I love the office as a matter
of fact one of my relaxing shows uh this
year has been revisiting the office and
I never actually finished after Michael
Scott left I had an attitude problem
when it was originally airing and now I
am at the very final season I got about
10 episodes left of the final season and
I'm already feeling sad that feeling
when you're like man I've committed
hundreds of episodes to this I'm already
feeling sad at the thoughts that I have
to eventually say goodbye to this so
there's this one part of me that is
semi-excited I don't know if the right
word's excited I'm intrigued because
it's Greg Daniels that there could be
something
of quality to it but at the same time
I think what people have been really
like everyone is constantly asking you
know for an office reunion or an office
reboot uh with the you know like like
Steve Carell and and stuff not not a new
cast of characters
that's what people have really been
wanting but I I think no matter what you
do you're not really going to win and if
you have a shot at doing an all right
job
um yeah oh I'll watch the pilot I'm not
exactly excited but
you know I I can't I mean line if I said
I wasn't curious
yeah definitely so I was a massive
massive British office fan like I
literally can say say it line for line
from beginning to end it was one of the
first DVDs I ever got the the first two
seasons and then the Christmas special
and I was absolutely obsessed with it
tried watching the American one that the
first episode of that was pretty much a
remake of the first British one just
didn't gel with it just thought they
were doing impressions didn't really
like it that much years later checked it
out again with the wife
loved it though I genuinely think it's
one of the best TV shows ever made you
know that that British one always has a
special place in my heart but I actually
think at some point the American one
surpassed it
the second season they make it they make
it their own in the second season they
were trying to mirror to they didn't
they didn't know how to just make it
their own in the first season then after
40 year old virgin came out they found a
way to redo the show where they found
their own voice with all the characters
and the style and changing Michael Scott
so even when I restarted it I skipped
the first season
um I like I just start from the second
season
yeah so me and the wife love it we've
watched it through three times I think
or in total because we every year or so
we we try and watch through the office
and yeah she I asked her I said have you
heard the reboot in the office she said
it's difficult isn't it when she doesn't
talk that Posh it's difficult isn't it
when people love something so much and
they want to bring back the good old
memories but it's never quite as good as
it was and ultimately it kind of leaves
people a bit disappointed and we just
hope as fans that you know they can
recapture it but it'll never truly live
up to it and I went wow you're being so
negative I'm sick here
um but yeah she she's kind of a bit like
that on it I feel the same you know it's
such a beloved show I think it's danger
I mean I even in the first place though
I thought making them an American
version of it was dangerous and then
obviously turned out to be what it was
rebooting it's a bit different I'm
guessing that because Greg Daniels is
involved like gonna get some returning
cast members to do maybe cameos uh you
know get people watching be like oh I've
heard Jim shows up this week we'll have
to check it out that sort of thing so
I'm guessing that they're going to do
stuff like that I don't feel like it's
gonna run as long as the the other shot
like the the first version of it um
because that just went on for seasons
and seasons and Seasons so it probably
might might manage one or two maybe
three and then they'll kind of go from
there but I don't feel like it'll ever
truly live up to it but prove me wrong
guys I think it just needs to get to a
second season because Greg Daniels is
kind of like the Sundance Kid he always
needs that second shot to really perfect
it even with Parks and Recreation which
I believe he might have been behind too
um that needed kind of a similar
trajectory first season was kind of all
right didn't Jive too well and then they
really reformulated their focus with
their League character and the cast for
their second season and that's when the
show becomes really great so so if they
can survive to the second season they
might have a shot but the difference is
with the office it is it is just such a
massively beloved show and I like I
think that I think it's pretty apparent
the the fan base for the American
version just that continues to grow it
the me the Zeitgeist for it just
continues to expand and people discover
it way more than they discovered the
British version and I I it's gonna be
it's kind of hard when it's going to be
a big comparison game if anything I feel
like an extras reboot I don't think they
should reboot extras but I like to show
extras a lot too I thought yeah it was
really good and I feel like that'd be
more relevant to today in in a lot more
ways yeah no I think extras would be
really good
um Life's too short or life is short the
one with Warwick Davis brilliant so
funny oh that's a corny one too yeah
yeah that Liam Neeson scene oh I watched
it the other day for my Return of the
Jedi breakdown and just absolutely kills
me it's so so bad it's so cringy uh but
yeah lots of stuff to live up to hoping
it's good Greg Daniels being involved
that's got me feeling at least some
Faith you know if it was just a
completely random show or an ad thing uh
but maybe you know if if they get to
that second season or maybe they just
knock it out the park in the first one
we'll have to see I think they kind of
operate on audience feedback almost and
I I think you can really see the
difference between season one and two
like even the the way the cameras are
shot and stuff of it it's clear that you
sort of filmed that and then learned and
realized what all their mistakes were
and decided to go in a slightly
different direction and kind of fine
tune and fix it for season two now lots
of things going on in the world
obviously I'm out in the UK you're out
in America Greg but did you know with
surfsharkvpn I can instantly at the
flick of a switch join the us see what
you guys get on streaming that we don't
and you can see what I get on streaming
now did you know great knew that I do
that did you know Greg in in England
right there's a there's a special tab on
Disney plus called star where we've got
all the stuff you guys pay extra for on
Hulu you just switch to England it's all
included you get it all free don't tell
anyone who might be watching getting one
trouble the the Netflix UK options are
better too A lot of the time I gotta say
debatable we don't have as good of a
movie range as you guys sometimes times
I'll check it out and be like oh well
it's like spider verse and stuff we we
know we never get stuff like that and
but yeah surf shark is basically an
amazing VPN too that can help you switch
countries but also beyond that it keeps
your data safe when you're browsing
online there's lots of shady companies
out there cyber criminals and basically
people who just want to take your data
analyze it potentially sell it on and
using a VPN it just keeps that all safe
you don't have to worry about it when
you're browsing the web and you know if
you've got a family member who might be
a bit on the young side doesn't exactly
know what they're doing just keep them
protected by using surfsharkvpn it also
helps with YouTube too and as you guys
know if you've been following the
channel or Terminator 2 breakdown that
got blocked everywhere outside of
America because a certain Studio decided
that they did want to give us the rights
to do a breakdown on it I was telling
people we're sorting it out with a
copyright stuff but it's going to take
about 60 days to get that video back
online publicly however if you just
switch to the US you can instantly watch
it and yeah it really helped people out
now a VPN also encrypts your online data
and helps secure your personal
information when you use free public
Wi-Fi which can often be a gold mine for
hackers surf sharks clean web feature
blocks ads trackers malware and phishing
attempts allowing you to surf the web
safely and right now guys we've got a
special deal where you're getting an
extra three months free by using my code
spoilers at the link in the description
so just go to the link in the
description use the code spoilers you're
gonna get an extra three months free
just by using that code surf shark also
offer a 30 day money back guarantee so
there's no risk to trying it out so just
go with the link in the description use
the code spoilers and get an extra three
months free and yeah check it out get
yourself a lovely VPN thanks I will I
would like to add that I am a staunch
believer when it comes to vpns we were
once hacked at real Rejects and I didn't
even notice it was happening for a year
where they were siphoning off money
every month from our Google AdSense and
it racked up the thousands it was just
like it was it was a clever way of doing
it so ever since then I have been very
adamant about enabling VPN on the on on
my end so yeah for protection I really
believe in it I really do yeah the Cyber
criminals are getting very sophisticated
and yeah this is just going to keep you
safe
put it on you don't have to worry about
anything now
looking forward to the future Greg we've
got a lot of positive news to finally
talk about finally the wga strike is
pretty much over now it's not 100 over
there's a tentative deal in place needs
to be signed but as you know it's very
very rare that these Things Fall Apart
and the fact that they've agreed on it
got things in place
it's already positive news
Greg I've put a link to the statement do
you want to read it and I'm just gonna
sit back and go ah thank God this is
really positive I love this dear members
we have reached a tentative agreement on
a new 2023 MBA which is to say an
agreement in principle on all deal
points subject to drafting final
contract language what we have won in
this contract most particularly
everything we have gained since May 2nd
is due to the willingness of this
membership to exercise its power to
demonstrate its solidarity to walk side
by side to endure the pain and
uncertainty of the past
146 days it is the leverage generated by
your strike in concert with the
extraordinary support of our Union
siblings that finally brought the
companies back to the table to make a
deal we can say with great pride that
this deal is exceptional with meaningful
gains and protections for writers in
every sector of the membership that is a
very different tone and tender than we
are used to when wga he is talking about
the contracts love to hear it love to
hear it but this is the path to getting
back on track thank God because it has
been all like I can't even remember when
this thing they've been on strike for so
long I can't actually remember life
before they were striking and I never I
felt like it wasn't it wasn't ever going
to end it was one of those things where
yeah I mean obviously the actors are
still on strike they're 74 days deep in
this 154 day thing shows how long it can
really go on for but it's brilliant news
you know they obviously sound very happy
about it like I said it's not 100 in
place it takes weeks and weeks to get
lawyers drafted in to check over read
over all the fine print get everything
signed off then start setting up
contracts to work on things and blah
blah blah but in terms of what's going
on right now the the the wga have said
there's no need to continue striking if
you have a project you want to work on
you're able to go back to I believe
they've said you're able to go back to
that and for example today Craig marzins
confirmed that the last of us too has
begun they've started working on that
season all the talk show hosts you know
the late night ones where they had to
stop doing them because they were
writers involved they're able to go
Barrymore is so happy right now she is
splendiferously change man she should
have waited the week she if she's given
it a week yeah wait one week reacted too
early man yeah so very very good news
obviously I'm very relieved for them
it's nice to see them get a win from
what they've said you know we don't know
all the ins and outs of it yeah I know
some deals have been posted about but
I'm sure that there will still be
details that we don't fully know about
yet um but just to hear how alleviated
that sounds and just for a victory for
the workers you know what I mean there's
obviously two sides when these things
come out and whenever we've talked about
it I think our perspective and positions
being very clear but there's been people
who've came from the other side and
talked about stuff and yeah we've always
been hopeful that would be a positive
resolution that would be good for the
workers and it sounds like that what
that's what they've got and that's a
real Victory and it shows you know the
power of unity the power of Union
I know a lot of people made a hell of a
lot of sacrifices they wait they went
very long time without getting paid
stood their ground and yeah it's worked
out and hopefully Holly would appreciate
that the fact that they've got these
people back and can get back to work and
start making money again for them um I'm
get you know we we have villainized the
the studios and stuff but I'm guessing
it would have been stressful for them
too kind of
having to sort things out and you know
as as much as they've been painted out
as the bad guys I'm gonna sound like I'm
scabbing before but you know what I'm
trying to say Greg you know it's not a
nice situation to be in for anyone like
of course it's just not nice having to
deal with this stuff you know everyone
wants to go to work everyone wants to be
creative everyone wants to make money
and support themselves live financially
stable and just to have stuff like this
it's stressful on every single party
um so great to hear that in place
hopefully this kickstarts things with
the SAG after group because
Unfortunately they still can't go back
to filming things yet you might have
remembered earlier in the year when the
strikes first happened the writers went
on strike the actors kept working anyway
but now we're kind of in the opposite to
that where the writers are back to work
but they're not filming because the
actors are still on strike right so yeah
what's your thoughts on it Greg what
what did you think are you happy do you
think the SAG strike's gonna get shut
down well not shut down but you know
they're gonna negotiate very soon and
get things uh get things in place I
think it helps give them a decent guide
on what they can do because they're
asking for it's like similar terrain but
plenty of differences at the same time
of what they're asking for because the
field is different and what is put on
display is different so
I think you could still go on for a
while longer but this gives hope and at
least get and like I said a decent guide
right now I'm just really happy that we
saw I didn't think this would actually
get resolved until even with the writers
until 2024 no matter how many times it
looked really close
but I I am genuinely feeling uh really
happy about it because on a very biased
personal note like one of my main as
Paul really knows uh one of my main
passions is actually screenwriting that
is actually my main passion you know
um and I think even on the on my channel
whenever we review movies it's where my
my writer brain is usually the thing
that's kind of reviewing stuff and
I was like I want to say three weeks
before I'm not going to go into too much
detail about it it was like three weeks
prior to the writer strike actually
taking place
I had a script that was working on with
a pretty with it okay uh director of
sorts and it was going through a really
well regarded agency and then the agency
really loved it so they started to
actually pitch it really fast and it was
gaining this momentum and I was like
texting Paul like oh my God it's going
to this production company oh my I was
shocked I've never had anything of that
sort ever happen in my life where it was
going through like these these people
that you guys would know who they are
and then the writer strike happened and
at first it was like ah well that's a
bummer that finally started getting
momentum in my life uh for this big
passion of mine
um but you know really quick into the
strike actually happening
quickly realized that well no this is
this is a good thing you know like my My
Life currently is not depending on you
know income from being a writer
and what they're fighting for it's like
they're fighting they're doing the the
labor the sacrifice they're putting in
all the hard effort
and
I'd rather have something potentially
sell post this where I can feel a little
bit safer and more protective because
the cliche was how especially for an
up-and-coming or new writers of how
over it can easily be so I'm I'm
really grateful for the fight that has
taken place and uh for that thing
getting put on Halt and allowing me
eventually sometime soon to be able to
go back to to pitching this I don't know
if it'll get sold or not but either way
you know I'm not going to stop writing
I'm not going to stop pursuing that and
this just makes me feel really happy
that they managed to pull off this fight
and just hear I don't know the details
but just hearing that last statement I'm
like wow they seem actually genuinely
enthusiastic about
hey we we are we actually got something
good here this is the and and the cliche
of being a screenwriter is just how
over you are all the time and so
I'm just grateful right now I'm feeling
very grateful on a personal note and
hopeful for my own future if because at
the time people were just other
screenwriters I know like actual working
screenwriters I know were saying you
should just take whatever deal you can
get just just whatever you want doesn't
matter just take it and now I'm like oh
I might have some level of security here
you know
yeah well I've just been reading some
tweets online and um there's been lots
of people well exes online and there's
been people who've actually said a very
good point which is things like the Drew
Barrymore situation you know there was a
lot of backlash to it and last time with
the writers strike there wasn't really
that backlash when it came to these late
night talk shows and guest stuff and I
think there was a lot of people who
actually stood strong with the writers
and and the actors now and it was very
publicized and you know the studios were
definitely I I feel like they they might
have realized they can't get away with
what they could have in the past and
this might have made the deal better but
yeah shout out to the entire Union well
done guys you know you had a lot of
support behind you the deals obviously
worked out great well done uh I'm very
happy for you guys it's been a hell of a
long time that we've been covering this
and finally some positive news finally
finally finally so yeah well done guys
um podcast on the heavy spoilers Channel
we went too positive this time Paul too
positive we'll find a way to click bait
the thumbnail we'll put Bob Iger looking
angry and someone behind him looking
happy and you guys you fought for the
same tricks every time
ending the strike the right choice yeah
now speaking of um people who fall for
the same tricks every single time
there's a Morton Scorsese interview
that's came out Greg I did not read it
Greg if you let's be honest if you were
a journalist in the like you've got 15
minutes with Martin Scorsese mate you
can ask him whatever you want about
films movies whatever you want what are
you gonna what you're gonna ask
I would ask him what's your opinion on
comic book movies Martin Scorsese help
me get this article seen I want to know
Martin's car says is my favorite
director of all time all time favorite
director of all time so I would have so
many questions I am so excited for
killers at the flower Moon
um I mean chomping at the bit to get
good seats man it's really hard to get
some good seats and it's also the
weekend the Taylor Swift concert's
happening I'm like God damn it this is
really there's gonna be a lot to squeeze
in it's a lot to squeeze in
um and all I saw were quote tweets about
because you sent me the article and this
article's thick it's really dense
there's a lot in here didn't read it yet
but then I go on Twitter so I'm like why
is Paul sending this to me and he's
trending and of course it's all about
what his opinion on franchises are it
has nothing to do with any of the
amounts of depth that are I'm sure are
in here that I give you a really good
insight into the mindset of the
well-revered legendary director that is
Martin Scorsese but it's all about his
opinion on comic book movies and what
franchising has become it's just more of
the same like the quotes were kind of
just more of the same of what he's
already said prior I think hell
I think hell for Martin Scorsese is him
making like putting years and years of
his life into a film and then sitting
down to talk about it and the first
question is so what what did you think
about the Marvel's mate are you excited
to see the marbles
um so that's pretty much what's happened
so he he was asked uh as talented and
dedicated as you are can the industry
can filmmakers just make movies that
they want to anymore and he said well
the industry's over in other words the
industry that I was part of we're
talking almost what 50 years ago it's
like saying to somebody in the 1970s who
made silent films watching things
happened but of course Scorsese has
theories
so the interview says they've done the
quotes weird but he says that studios
are no longer interested in supporting
individual voices that Express their
personal feelings or their personal
thoughts or personal ideas on a big
budget what's happened now is that
they're pigeon told into what they call
Indies which is very true you know if
someone makes a a smaller film where
they they put they're all into it it's
often seen as an indie film rather than
being like a you know a big franchise
but we'll see maybe that might change
with a Creator but even that still kind
of feels like a it's a studio film
almost
um and then he he basically gets
described as a retro upgrade defender of
how things used to be because of the way
he makes film you know he goes more
towards Cinema rather than being like
big budget over the top special effects
things
um and then of course what they're
trying to do is basically pitch it like
get them to walk down the path towards
talking about comic movies
um and what he said is that there's
there's a little quote about Christopher
Nolan
um which I'll quickly dig out
so he thinks what the danger of films
and the comic book entertainment
industry is that it's what it's doing to
our culture because there's going to be
Generations now that think these are the
only movies that's what movies are and
then the interviewer said I think people
already think that and Scorsese replied
by saying they already think that which
means that we have to then fight back
stronger and it's got to come from the
Grassroots level it's got to come from
the filmmakers themselves you'll have
you know the safety brothers and you'll
have Chris Nolan you know what I mean
and hit him from all sides hit him from
all sides and don't give up let's see
what you got go out there and do it Go
reinvent don't complain about it but
it's true because we've got to save
Cinema so he's very much seeing it as
you know the comic book and I don't the
thing with Scorsese right is you know
whenever someone asks them this stuff
that sometimes will be a point where he
actually admits that he doesn't really
watch comic book movies all that much
anymore or he hasn't really seen that
many and I personally don't feel it's
necessarily a comment on comic book
movies I think it's more just the fact
say say instead of comic book movies the
film industry just kept making anime
movies over and over and over again and
it like anime adaptations and it got to
a point where they were very clearly
made by the Numbers they'd kind of lost
their love and they were just knocking
them out because they thought they made
money I think Scorsese would be saying
the same thing about them it's the fact
it's more the fact that comic book
movies in general have dominated the
industry and almost pushed other things
out that would normally get made but
studios are so focused on making these
films that it's it because they they
there was a point where they made so
much money back that that's kind of died
off a bit because I think people are
getting a bit sick of how little their
sort of changing and doing different
things and I think scores sometimes you
would be saying the same thing but
obviously comic book movies have got a
big fan base they're very popular and
that's kind of why I get steamrolled
towards answering these questions and
personally I I feel what what he's
saying is that it's almost like a death
of creativity the fact that they're
constantly doing the same things over
and over again which I even feel
watching them sometimes
um but yeah what do you think Greg I
mean I I think he's talking more about
just franchise filmmaking in general you
know you could apply a lot of what he's
saying to something like Fast and
Furious they get these directors for the
Fast and Furious franchises and you know
they had James wand direct one of the
really good ones uh Fury is seven uh
that F Gary gray on board they get these
directors and I cannot see their
distinct voice on them like there's it
they a lot of times they're just a Hired
Hand in some ways it's equivalent to you
know we were just talking about the
office and and on a recent than this
recent season I saw one episode directed
by Brian Cranston another episode
directed by John Krasinski and I know a
lot of I've met a couple of directors
who have talked about working on network
TV where it's still just a writer's
medium and an editor's Medium you're not
really really
you're not really directing or providing
something truly unique or new uh to the
game and this is what a lot of the
directors become we're going to talk a
little bit about Nia DeCosta and the
Marvels later on and I imagine we're
going to bring up something that she
talked about recently and this is sort
of what Studios pump out with their
franchises is Formula director not
really being able to provide the
creativity their Ingenuity have a unique
Vision to it and it's a lot of control
behind it and I think that's more of
what he is talking about and I don't
think that there's actually anything
really wrong about what he's saying and
I feel like most of us have already
caught on to that fact we know that
Marvel is such a committee machine and
rare is the day where you get that
unique perspective you know I've been
re-watching Loki season one in
preparation for season two and I forgot
just how brilliantly shot that move that
show is and uh how it had a distinct
voice to it and then how it was later
followed up by Multiverse of Madness
which I really really did enjoy a lot
and but you could feel it being at odds
between a Sam raymie unique voice and
then having to trim it down and view the
MCU movie and meet uh you know a
checklist and I think that's yeah it's
kind of franchises in general is what oh
I guess he even talks about it you know
he says here that that doesn't mean that
you don't have incredible directors and
special effects people doing beautiful
artwork you know and a lot of it is kind
of just I want to say disposable
or necessarily forgettable it's
a lot of it just doesn't really stick
with you it's kind of weird how we get
movies that cost like hundreds of
millions of dollars and most of the time
when you stop watching it you don't
really think about it you know like they
don't really lead to a well most movies
don't really lead to a reflective
experience anymore and it's kind of
always been that way I think you know
like a large quantity of them but if
we're talking about the truly big films
the big box office ones a lot of times
you don't really walk away thinking
about it and I I think that's why a
champion but like what Barbie did
because that could have easily been such
a CL there's there's one scenario of
that movie that could have been the
exact movie all of us thought it could
have been of a typical kind of comedy
and riddled with just advertisement and
whatnot and
at the end of the day it still really
feels like Greta Gerwig made the movie
she wanted to make which is the last
thing I think most of us probably
anticipated before watching that movie
even if you like it or not it's still
clearly her distinct voice
and I think that's kind of what we need
a little bit more of because doesn't he
talk about he talks about in this
article at some point if I'm not
mistaken which I thought was really
interesting
of how he left Warner Brothers after The
Departed because they wanted to
franchise it out and I thought from day
one they wanted to do like the sequel
with Mark Wahlberg's character
and I thought from day one that that was
a strange choice and I didn't realize he
actually left Warner Brothers because of
that which is surprising because
he for the longest time he had never
he's one of the biggest directors of all
time yet
he didn't win an Oscar until that movie
for directing
and I thought there would have been a
sense of oh this is where I belong you
know and uh it's kind of crazy that
and Nolan have left Warner Brothers
because of their way of handling stuff
well we kind of saw something with the
discourse around the Joker too when that
was announced like I remember saying
look I I I'm really excited to see a
sequel to Joker but there was lots of
people who were like no they're ruining
it they should have just left it at that
one movie did really well really like
critically acclaimed lots of people
enjoyed it I think I think it's one of
the best comic book movies of all time
but I was like I'd love to see more
um and it there was definitely a
discourse around that though where I
could totally see things from other
people's point of view where they were
saying they're they're franchising it
they're just they're making it shallow
they're only doing a second one because
the first one made money and they don't
actually care about the art or the story
of it and yeah I can see exactly what
he's saying there was a recent example
Greg werewolf finite they've just
announced that they're doing a color
version of it
um which is oh it's obviously because
you know there are people out there who
just won't watch black and white things
and the studio is just like make it
color they bring those people in which
totally disregards the entire point of
that of werewolf by night it was meant
to be a play on the B movies of the 50s
those horror films and yeah playing that
up in the Marvel Universe and it even
had a bit at the end where it turned to
color and I'm just thinking like
storytelling
but yeah what are you doing like you
don't understand why you made this in
the first place and things like that
really kind of
just scream to me that that exactly what
score says he's saying and I I agree
with him you know I don't I enjoy comic
book movies obviously I wish he'd just
sit down and watch some and it might
change his mind but I think what he's
criticizing more is the franchise idea
where it's like let's just make the same
thing over and over again and make as
much money as possible he sees films as
being an art form whereas Studios often
see things see them as being a way to
make money
and lots of people are hung up on the
the Christopher Nolan comment Scott
Derrickson actually posted a tweet
before which he's now deleted and
basically saying how do I tell Martin
Score says he that Christopher Nolan
directed The Batman Trilogy
um but I think what score says he's
saying is but we aren't you know we all
know that yeah we know the difference
yeah we all know that no one needs no
needs to be freaking pedantic about the
damn thing we we know there's a
difference with that you know yeah and I
think like Nolan obviously he I mean he
set the grounds for like the next 10
years that the Dark Knight in Iron Man
those set the ground for the next 10
years of comic book movies you know
Amazing Spider-Man and yeah Amazing
Spider-Man was the perfect example of
something that was just like they've
made this darker because it's a bit more
like Nolan's stuff and yeah it's uh
it's it's you know it's I do feel like
it's almost a waste of an interview but
obviously you know these sites want
clicks and they want people to get
outraged about it and be like what's
this old man talking about and it's like
well he's one of the the greatest
filmmakers of all time you might not
agree with him but you should respect
his opinion and we saw something similar
with James Gunn recently where he also
did the same thing talked crap about
movies but you know he's a filmmaker he
has his own point of view I think Mario
Score says he's a a like an amazing
filmmaker and he doesn't just make
gangster movies you know like he's has
he has such a what he does have a wider
genre Than People realize and I don't
think I know Rotten Tomatoes is not the
end I'll be all but I'm not sure if he
has a single rotten movie
I I could be wrong about that but yeah
Cape Fear Maybe
which one I'm gonna quit Cape Fear I'm
gonna quickly Google that that would be
my case fear I love Cape Fear that is
such a good movie
original original so much better so much
better I like the original too but I
love what Martin Esther says he did with
the reboot uh with his version I thought
he really made it his own I really love
that one even he even kept the score the
same what you're talking about made his
own oh dude 75 critics 77 audience score
I thought this girl was so scary in that
one too he was oh yeah right yeah yeah I
like Nick Nolte's performance uh I just
love the original so much that it's like
please don't remake it please don't
remake it
um but yeah moving on on to something
modern Score says he I'm sure he's
bloody he can't wait to see it the
Marvels so obviously there's been a lot
to talk about it this week there was a
weird report it's been kind of back back
and forth because the the initial budget
was reported to be 130 million yeah and
then I feel like Disney the next day
were like well whoa no we we've spent
loads talking about extras Greg before
have you seen that bit with Les Dennis
where he's on the phone and he's trying
to get the tabloids interested in him
again and he's like no tell her tell him
I was down the market so I seen Les
Dennis down the market and he was
spending a shitload and then he hangs up
I feel like that's what Disney were
doing with her like 130 million no we
spent a shitload on this movie yeah we
spent we overspent if anything so yeah
according to the what budget Disney had
put out
um it's a 274 million budget the UK
right we're desperate for people to come
spend 200 million dollars in this
country so if you come over here we're
gonna give you a tax break so that 274
million they get a 55 million dollar tax
break because they filmed in the UK
obviously we get some of that 200
million you know what I mean so you can
see why they're doing it
um and that drops it down to 219 I think
but it's still a very very expensive
movie
um
yeah which is crazy and it's only about
a 90 minute movie as well which that was
the thing that shocked me the most I'm
like how how are they spending this much
money on a 90 minute move me when
oppenheimer's a hundred million dollar
Budget on a three-hour movie with a much
bigger cast
don't fully get my head around it but
yeah near the cost has been out doing
the rounds talking about stuff and she
made it very clear that Kevin foggy's
taking control obviously from what we've
heard behind the scenes there's been
lots of reshoots on this movie uh
reshoots to let's say a reshot there
it's been lots of reshooting there um so
you can see how the balloon they
ballooned up the budget it was also shot
during covid so again
makes a lot of sense Greg the big
question on everyone's lips will it make
a billion will it make a billion dollars
no no no no way man I mean Captain
Marvel did really well because it was a
Captain Marvel really had the benefit of
not only being sandwiched between you
know Infinity war and end game but the
infinity War
I want to say post-credit scene was
right with Nick Fury the way they set it
up was Oh Captain Marvel's gonna be very
important to what segues us into end
game you know and uh it was also the
time too where we didn't have many
female superheroes still don't really uh
but that was like that was a really big
deal at the time as well
and it really had the benefit of writing
that momentum
this
does not have anywhere near as much
interest you know like it costs about as
much if not more to produce than Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania again trailers
are uh Rotten Tomatoes is apparently a
bigger deal than trailers are but
looking at the trailer views the
trailers have not matched The View count
of Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania as
we all know quantumania severely
underperformed at the box office
this has to do better than quantumania
to make a profit and I'm rooting for it
the movie does look fun I'd like it to
be good I'd rather have a good Marvel
movie than a bad Marvel movie but right
now it doesn't seem like audiences flock
to movies that are just okay and it
still needs to be special in some regard
or else we're all just gonna most people
will just wait for it to come out on
Disney plus then there needs to feel
some importance or necessity of seeing
it the benefit Dune has been pushed out
of the uh has been pushed next year so
it doesn't have to compete with that and
if this has good word of mouth who knows
but I you know it's freaking like
especially Iman villani I am I cannot
stress this enough I think she is one of
the best cast people in the MCU I love
her Casting I think she's very
underrated for like just how Pitch
Perfect of a casting Choice she really
is
she's it's seamless natural so I am
insanely excited that she gets to have a
big screen debut following up from Miss
Marvel so I really I there's things in
here that I genuinely as a fan am really
really looking forward to I don't want
it to fail
I still do think that it's got a hurl to
overcome though man it doesn't look
some people will argue I've seen both
sides that are that are just very much
convinced it is for sure gonna bomb and
there's the other side that for sure
commits it's gonna 100 succeed and to me
I am apprehensive I I don't right now I
am currently leaning towards it is not
going to make the money that
Disney is hoping it'll ultimately need
to make but I would love to be wrong I
would love to be wrong especially with
this one I would
Disney's had a really bad yet and lots
of things are bombed
um I think the way that now I personally
don't think it will perform that well I
think it'll do okay I don't think it's
gonna knock it out the park I have heard
this is actually quite interesting stuff
in it like incursions and ties towards
that
um so that might draw people out for
second week in viewings and stuff I
don't think it's gonna completely bomb
but I think it's gonna be sort of around
the Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
level
that's partly due to the strikes but I
think the way the The Narrative after it
will get spun is like oh Marvel's gone
woke in the ruin everything
I can see those headlines already but
personally
I think the days of the billion dollar
Blockbuster comic book movie are pretty
much over that's how I feel I think
that'll that it will probably be that
way for a while I think 10.3 yeah I
think maybe up until Secret Wars I can
see that possibly kind honestly doing it
beforehand
but maybe the Batman too depend when
when the hell does that release anyway
uh that might be after it but I think
that you know the days of those billion
dollars they're not unfortunately I
think Joker too will be a billion I I
can see Joker 2 being a billion
yeah maybe yeah he could be right there
um to be fair yeah you could be right
but in terms of like you know Multiverse
and Madness didn't crack it Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 let's look at that for
a second that is the final Guardians
film everyone was thinking like oh some
characters are gonna die oh it's a big
send-off of the team that we absolutely
love one of the most popular teams in
the MCU well probably you know up there
next to the Avengers maybe can't think
of any other teams other than those and
maybe Thunder well Thunderbolts haven't
had a move yet but you know what I'm
saying uh so I I think that that kind of
indicated where the interest was at and
the fact that that didn't break a
billion considering it was James Gunn's
last movie The Last film of this team
everyone was expecting you know someone
to die and yeah the fact that that
didn't do it kind of indicated for me
that I don't think the Marvels will
break the billion Miss Marvel
unfortunately great TV show hasn't done
that well viewership wise secret
Invasion hasn't done that well
viewership Wise One Division which
introduced Photon really really well
um so yeah that might put people in and
obviously the first Captain Marvel movie
did really well so I do think it's got
the base is there to do quite well but I
just can't see it cracking that billion
however you know like you said June 2
has moved which I'm I'm surprised they
did that I think I I personally think
that the strikes might be resolved by
the time that comes around but you know
you never know and but Oppenheimer
managed to do it you know close to a
billion without having any of the cast
out there so who knows but yeah still
had their cast almost to the finish line
of this until the strikes happen right
like they were still no they were at the
premiere for half of it yeah they went
to the premiere and then walked out and
that was it you know what I mean it
wasn't like it wasn't like they were
there for the doing the whole press tour
they they got to the premiere and were
like right what time says oh strike
started off it was like um really
enjoying that no you're gonna leave
you've got to leave no come on my
scene's coming up Mercy I'm just about
to be in the movie no get the out
mate
Casey Affleck get the out
um so so yeah that was Nolan saying that
as well and he was like I'll tell you
what happened I'm gonna sit here I
wonder if they've seen it Oppenheimer
actually there's a countless scabbing if
you go and pay for a movie that you're
in oh think about that is it scabbing if
you pay to go watch a movie yeah or is
it just promote maybe yeah I don't know
maybe they've not seen it
um put Casey Affleck will not put him
poor KCF that's the quote of the video
today poor Casey don't put our context
and put it on Twitter I'll be in a lot
of trouble
um so yeah I I don't think it's gonna
crack the billion and I think audiences
in general are moving more away from
comic book movies you know three years
ago if Martin School says he had said
this there were pitchforks out for that
kind of everyone's going to kill
him this year everyone's like he might
have a point he might have a point look
at something yeah yeah and look at the
biggest movies this year I'm sure
somewhere we reported that the top three
this is the first time since like
2001 or something where the top three
highest grossing movies of the air
haven't been sequels right and now
they're some were connected to
franchises like Barbie and Super Mario
things like Oppenheimer it's shown the
audience is kind of moving maybe towards
you know looking at different things
because we have kind of seen these you
know these superhero movies a lot um
there's not that many out there that are
Reinventing the wheel
even though I like the flash you know
that that should have been like this
year's no way home and it's clear that
it just didn't connect with audiences
didn't interest them and yeah well I
think the Marvels is gonna it's it's
it'll do okay but I don't think it's
gonna completely break the bank and I
mean it's of course this is the point of
not giving on I kind of feel like maybe
audiences aren't getting enough credit
like franchises in general seem to be
dipping Fast and Furious yeah and that's
been going downhill
um Mission Impossible DC Universe has
been in samples and uh do all the DC
movies this year have not done well and
Indiana Jones
Indiana Jones there I feel like there's
another one is there one we're missing
there's gotta be another one we're
missing
bombed completely we don't even remember
it in and out of my sight Little Mermaid
reboot didn't do as strong as I hoped
that kind of counts yeah it did okay but
it didn't break the billion they were
expecting and also yeah I mean with
Marvel's uh back to the point about if
the sack strike if it happens to be over
in the next month that's that'd be good
that could help the Marvels because I
think the reported decrease or or
negative box office effect is 10 to 20
on box office so if they can get that
sex strike over and start pushing Brie
Larson and Gianna Paris and uh mon
villani on put them on hot ones get it
going get them on their wired auto
complete interviews get it all going uh
then there might be a chance to really
see what they can
how much influence actors really do have
on a box office yeah they're I mean
they're all like when they've acted in
like photo shoots before and hung out
together and stuff they've all they've
been so funny and I think I'm oppressed
who are those three would really be good
and help sell the movie and yeah it's
just about that kind of Rapport and I I
actually think they would benefit the
box office quite a lot you know I've
talked about how some starts I don't
really necessarily feel like it makes a
massive difference uh but yeah I feel
like those guys in a room together just
busting off jokes would be good
promotion kind of thing you could clip
and then uh yeah just put it on Twitter
don't click the next video of me
watching totemo Casey Affleck just turn
that turn the sound off for that turn
swipe it away
oh Jesus that should be the thumbnail
title poor Casey off like quotes
you in the background going like and me
at the front doing that like a Mr Beast
thumbnail uh disgraceful
um so speaking of disgraces and people
that have been canceled Justin roilin's
been replaced and the new Rick and Morty
voices are now out here we go Greg what
did you think of them
I haven't heard it yet I'm apprehensive
about hearing it because is it um is it
worth it I'm sure they're good
that something pretty much the same I
actually played the trailer and I was
like oh I don't I'm like it crossed my
mind did they film this before all the
cancellations not film it but you know
what I mean record the voices before all
the cancellations went down it didn't
and Morty sounds a bit kind of not off I
would say it was the same person's voice
if they were older so they might go with
a whole he's a teenager he's growing up
his balls have dropped Something's
Happened his voices change slightly but
as far as Rick goes I I think it sounds
exactly the same and I think if he
didn't know they were different voices
you would have no idea exactly what it
is I guess you just think it was the
same person I guess my main
my main thing about it is that sure I I
I never doubted for one second that they
would be there's been like great
impersonators on Tick Tock alone when it
com when it came to them people can do
creative impersonations of them so of
course they were able to find someone so
no no that's like a surprise to me and
Kudos and congratulations to someone who
got that voiceover gig that's amazing
I'm sure I hope they get paid well for
it they've actually kept it quiet who it
is they're not saying oh really yeah
they're just saying it's like a secret
voice actor so I'm thinking deep down
what if it's just in Ryland again
that'd be funny but
if it's that let's say it it is just
someone else Justin Royal and he he
provided such level of improv that was
that everyone who's talked about when it
comes to Rick and Morty a big part of
writing around it and crafting an
episode revolved a lot around the Improv
that he would provide so it's more than
just The Voice work it's more than just
delivery you know and it's also also he
knows the characters so well obviously
you know he he lived he breathed his
characters these characters into
existence
so it's not just about getting someone
who could do a voice you know you need
someone who can really embody who the
characters are and also have the level
of improv skill as well that helps drive
a lot of the absurdist elements and
craziness of of what makes Rick and
Morty Rick and Morty you know and that's
the part of it that I uh yeah I mean
it's it's not just Justin Roiland you
got a team of writers you got you know
animators you got a whole bunch of other
people surrounding what makes a Rick and
Morty episode a Rick and Morty episode
it does I guess we'll see how much of
that essential ingredient
Beyond just Voice work was Justin
Roiland when it comes to when the season
comes out they they're gonna need it to
be great they're really really really
gonna need it to be great because if it
dips at all in quality
or execution the audience voices they
will be heard yeah so Adult Swim have
actually come out and said that they're
gonna keep the voice actors secret until
the season 7 premiere and they've their
statements being we want to show we want
the show to speak for itself we believe
in the strength of the season and our
new voices that's smart so yeah sounds
like it's AI it's gonna be AI yeah
they honestly could
I don't see why they just didn't do that
yeah so uh that's the that's the big one
of the big stories now lastly we're
gonna talk about the Nielsen streaming
chart so hell yeah sometimes we get make
mistakes we didn't actually think that
Ahsoka had done all that well
um there was I think the reports
released from Samba TV Disney were like
whoa mate 14 million people watched it
uh we now have the Nielsen numbers in
and it's actually done really well
um so off it's number of its two
episodes It's had 829 uh minutes viewed
per week or something I don't know how
this whole thing works but um in
comparison to it you know it's only got
two episodes the next one up above it is
Gray's Anatomy which has 417 episodes
that got 932. suits is actually number
one in the streaming charts uh if you
can believe it Greg we need to start
covering that Jesus
I didn't even know it was a big show I
saw a clip of it and I was like huh this
show looks good and then I watched the
first three episodes and I loved it it's
a really it's a fun show man it's really
enjoyable yeah yeah I need to watch it
out
um so that's number one still 135
episodes
Bluey that's got 140. who is Aaron
Carter that's actually number two with
seven episodes and that's got a thousand
minutes so not even you know that much
higher than Ahsoka considering how many
episodes there are in comparison to that
so soccer has actually done really well
um but then yeah as as two because some
of these are just one episode that
premieres it was the premiere it was the
premiere
um so the Nielsen charts haven't counted
from episode three onwards I don't think
so they're carrying an episode one and
two as as okay a two episode debut but
some of the comparisons they're making
are the things like saying like beating
Loki but Loki only had like a one
episode premiere yeah it's kind of a
weird comparison especially when you're
doing this off of minutes watched you
know
yeah it's a bit of a bit of a weird
thing but uh yeah that's how the numbers
have come out we're back to Shilling for
Disney again Greg oh the calling us a
show list this week hell yeah top 10
streaming movies
you on so not invited to my bar mitzvah
that Adam Sandler movie with his
daughter that's number one I heard it
was a good nepotism movie though I
watched half of it and I was we were
actually watching it last week just
before the podcast and I kept checking
my watch like oh don't come on please
hit please hit recording time soon so I
think I saw like the first hour of it it
was exactly what you'd expect completely
inoffensive High School drama about with
Adam and Adam Adam Sandler comedy bit of
her I heard she was actually good though
the daughter or of of of the Sandman I
heard she was actually good yeah it
seemed fine for what it was you know it
wasn't I don't think it was that
demanding acting wise it just kind of be
yourself a high school student in the
Sandman way
yeah so the flash came in at number two
people have been like a bit down on it
saying that its numbers are the lowest
DC EU film in terms of streaming wise
but you know it's just continuing the
whole story with the flash which is like
kind of sick about drawing on about it I
I feel like that that movie is just so
centered around lots of other things at
the moment at the conversation topics
but
I did well on video on demand so yeah
socket
yeah and then number three is The Monkey
King four is the Pope's Exorcist what is
this
no idea no idea
five was hot of stone which I watched
that Gal Gadot film six was the Super
Mario Brothers movie Seven was Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 8 was vacation
friends two never heard of that nine on
Disney was Moana still doing well can
see why they're doing a live action
remake of that like five years after it
released hell yeah and lastly Greg
lastly was the black demon which I've
never heard about but uh yeah that's
this week's show thank you again to Surf
shark for sponsoring us no doubt we'll
probably they'll be like can you change
that line in in the advert where you
mentioned that thing and be like oh
we've already recorded it we can't do it
yeah definitely check out the the link
in the description go check them out
keep yourself safe online and make sure
you also follow us on Spotify Amazon if
you're on either of those podcast
networks please leave us a review
because it genuinely makes so much
takes two seconds to do this is your job
this week mate I'm giving you an
impossible mission pretend I'm Tom
Cruise getting that mission now to you
be like you what I want you to be part
of the team we're going on a heist
what's what's the job Paul five stars on
whatever podcast Network you use it's an
impossible mission and then I'll put
play some
do it now
be careful man remember I got a
copyright claim for doing that yeah I do
actually that was a real real thing that
happened to me I just yeah with my mouth
I got a copyright clay
we we own your mouth Now Greg Paramount
Pictures yeah we own it you can't make
any noises that sound like they might be
the Mission Impossible theme ever
so yeah hopefully you guys have enjoyed
this week I'm very happy and alleviated
that the strikes well for the writers
anyway have come to an end
actors and staying strong with you but I
feel like the deal is going to get
locked very soon because they want to
get back to work and it's there's no
point getting the writers strike out the
way and be like ah whatever we'll push
the actors one back a couple of months
um so yeah hopefully you will hear on
that I'd loved if it was this time next
week but we'll see what happens
um but any final thoughts Greg anything
you want to roll back anything you want
me to edit out
thank you
I I I guess I'll clarify that when I
said that I don't see why they didn't
just use AI for Justin Roiland that I
was being sarcastic
um you were being sarcastic about the
Casey Affleck stuff like none of that
yeah but uh thanks again guys hope to
see you back next week hopefully we've
got some more positive news hope you
guys haven't hope you guys have watched
this video with a positive news because
you know we only do negative to get
those sweet negative clicks even though
we've been doing nothing but positive
news for five years now and the channels
have both been doing really well but
yeah we've decided to go negative at the
last minute you suck as you fell for it
no take care and uh thanks again for all
your support we're very privileged to
have you guys listening to us every week
and we love you love you